today President Trump met with
congressional leaders Republicans and
Democrats on that thorny issue of
immigration and he did something we
don't see often in Washington he let the
press in to film some of the discussions
what's an hour I mean look at dick
Durbin he doesn't look all that thrilled
but he's one of the president's most
vicious critics sitting right next to
the president as I've been saying for
many years many years during the anti
amnesty battles of 2006 7 and 2014 the
people have a right to see where
everybody's cards are in this game of
high-stakes poker for the nation and the
president made sure that happened in
quite a respectful manner this is an
idea I had last week I was sitting with
some of our great Republican senators
and we all agreed on everything let's
have the same meeting but let's add the
Democrats perhaps you'd like to say if
you want we can come together and reach
an agreement and when that happens I
think good things will happen in other
places Tom would you like to say
something I hope that this meeting can
be the beginning building trust between
our parties between chambers because I
know Bob where are you with the bill you
challenged us and we should step up to
that challenge and we're going to do it
in a bipartisan fashion but we have to
put our best foot forward setting aside
the substance of the negotiations for
just a moment one thing is abundantly
clear after today that media story that
they've been peddling for days and weeks
and even months that the president
doesn't have as a handle on things well
he was clearly in command he was
gracious and I think he couldn't have
been kinder to the 22 legislators in
attendance yet look at the way the
Washington Post headline characterized
the event we got a glimpse of Trump
negotiating today it didn't go well that
is just absolutely pathetic as usual
President Trump is like a powerful
political strength astringent he's
trying a good faith to include
mccr at sand the process and what does
he get for it nothing but grief from the
media now remember when President Obama
had his one measly round table at Blair
House with Republicans before the
Obamacare vote treat all Americans the
same under provisions of the law so that
they will know that geography does not
dictate what kind of health care they
would receive Thank You mr. president
look let me just make this point John
because we're not campaigning the
election is over well well today at the
White House the Pitti guttered dweller
author Michael Wolfe became even smaller
and I'm not talking about his diminutive
stature either I'm referring to Wolf's
phony narrative that President Trump is
somehow not mentally equipped for the
job
today we saw he's sharp he's savvy and
he's really impatient for solutions for
the American people if anything it's
Washington that's not able to keep up
with his pace the bureaucracy moves too
slowly for Trump and all that he wants
to get done it's hard to get done of how
glacially this whole thing goes so I
think it's about time that the Trump
hating media and the political elites
why not have their own fitness for their
own jobs examined call me crazy but I
actually think your abilities and your
fitness should be measured by your track
record in your accomplishments or lack
thereof think for a moment about the
politicians in both parties as well
who've failed their constituents with
stupid policies and ideas that did zero
except waste our hard-earned money or
suffocate economic opportunity just look
at the crime in Chicago and Baltimore
the homelessness the epidemic we're
seeing of it in San Francisco in LA and
as for the press let's forget let's not
forget that most of them were
embarrassed by their predictions of
President Hillary and they're still
failing their readers and their viewers
with the same old tropes that they tried
against Trump in 2016 how can he be a
race-baiting xenophobic bigot
which Donald Trump is two or three
months for any Republicans voted Donald
Trump started talking about the Muslim
ban I knew immediately at that moment
instead of that moment i I could never
vote for this guy and I lied everybody I
was vote for Jeb Bush and Jeb lost I'm
sorry
and he said Trump is kind of out of it
Jeb Bush could win his home state jo I
mean imagine if instead of elevating
these spurious claims of a nasty
crackpot journalists reporters spent
more time getting to understand the
hopes and dreams of Americans who are
outside of the Acela corridor get out of
the bubble boys
I actually think Trump is really growing
into the job quite well thank you very
much by any objective measure he's
accomplished more and more good for the
country in one year then I believe most
other presidents in my lifetime and now
as for the actual policy analysis of
what this bipartisan gaggle may do on
immigration there were some good signs
and some not-so-good signs today first
let's talk about the positive the
President reiterated his must-haves in
any daca deal we need a wall has to be a
bill to end chain migration cancel the
lottery program those three things are
paramount well in a perfect world we
would have enough Republicans and even a
few Democrats maybe who would pass the
Rays act that Tom cotton senator Perdue
act before we took any steps toward
rewarding those who are in the country
illegally citizenship shouldn't be
bargained away for some song with maybe
a green card shouldn't do it now to the
concerning part of the daca roundtable
this should be a bipartisan bill there
should be a bill of love truly should be
a bill of love and we can do that when
this group comes back hopefully with an
agreement this group and others from the
Senate from the house comes back with an
agreement I'm signing it I mean I will
be signing it I'm not going to say oh
gee I want this or what that
oh wait a second I hope the president
hasn't been reading that Jeb Bush
immigration book remember in 2014 when
Jeb described illegal immigration as an
act of love one like clockwork Jeb Bush
tweeted today encourage the president is
seeking bipartisan solutions to our
immigration challenges
I'll bet color me concerned well while
the president seems eager to do a daca
deal I would caution that this is not
the reason why he won the American
people elected him to protect their
security and well-being first so I have
five thoughts for the president and the
GOP number one focus on how immigration
affects the American worker in the
language that you use even when you talk
about doing something for the daca
so-called kids number two
Trump won because his position on
immigration differed from everyone
else's in that room for the most part so
we need to keep the focus on what's good
for American citizens and legal
immigrants law in order my friends
remains popular necessary to the Trump
agenda number three let's everyone be
honest that passing daca well it's not
going to be some magic elixir for
Americans the GOP is going to be drummed
out of office if they're seen as being
more compassionate toward illegals than
they are toward American citizens and
number four if we don't change our legal
immigration system and fast the melting
pot will break beyond repair
assimilation patriotic immigration and
merit must be central to any discussion
if we don't get this right we won't be
two countries we're going to be ten
countries number five if Republicans
can't get Democrats to agree on chain
migration getting rid of it we really
know that they care more about illegal
immigrants than the working Americans
that'll be good for Republicans of
course it'd be bad for the country
remember the u.s. went from nine million
immigrants to forty five million
immigrants coming in in just a half a
century that was the largest movement of
people in the history of the world
so whatever they finally agree on after
day we should all agree on this the
president is fully engaged and fully
committed to the tricky and often
unpleasant process of shaking up
Washington if he can get these
entrenched elites in DC to secure this
border and focus on the needs of the
American people in the immigration
debate that alone will be a massive
victory for this president and for the
country as the details of this daca plan
unfold we're going to be watching and
very closely and that's the angle